[Music]
you know it really shouldn't be homo
reptilia because homo is a genus of
mammals and these clearly are not
[Applause]
[Music]
all right folks we got the next
two-parter of series 5 we have the
hungry earth and cold blood written by
our current so showrunner Chris Chibnall
which of course means my comments are
gonna be filled with people complaining
about series 11 even though this episode
is nothing about series a lot ah this is
fine anyways so this is the return of
the Silurians and yes I'm gonna call
them that I'm not gonna call them Homo
Reptilia to the show now the Silurians
are a classic era monster first interst
introduced in the third dr. Zara with
Pertwee so bringing them back I think
was an interesting choice now this is
also an instance where I mean some
people who make these arguments will
make them regardless but this is
definitely one of those creatures where
you can't say that the modern era is
doing anything weird or disrespectful by
taking a political angle on this because
the Silurians have always been political
much like the way the Daleks have always
had a political angle to them because
the Daleks are Nazis and the Silurians
and the tension between them and human
beings was very reminiscent of the Cold
War in a number of points sort of a mash
up of of Cold War and concerns in
regards to native populations who were
displaced and we're like ah hello and
that's another kind of thing from the
classic era is there's a running thread
of the Silurians basically having a
point and the doctor really trying to
get things to work and they don't that's
kind of the running thing with the with
this entire species which really does
make you feel bad for the men again
makes this very true to the original so
there are a number of things that I
quite like about this it's missed
Smith is great in this particular
episode both Amy and Rory are really
good which is very helpful for what
happens at the end but I'll get there I
really like the character of Nazarene
but she had a terrific a rapport with
Smith like to the point that I kind of
wish they could have found an excuse to
keep her around or like have her come
back at some later date except the way
the episode ends II can't well I suppose
you could I mean the guy time-travels
yeah we could bring her back let's do it
like because I love her going to the
TARDIS and he's trying to talk her into
not coming with him he's like it it's
going to be dangerous she's like yes I
was crossing the road I'm like okay I
like you I like you a lot
so she was nice I dug her I liked the
redesign for the Silurians it's it's
much more it was much more human than
the original one was but also you know
the old classic monsters were very
rudimentary math so they couldn't do you
know fine latex really adheres to the
face moves with the facial movements of
the actors kind of work the way that we
can do now so I like that they had the
the masks which felt more like an homage
to the original design and then you take
it off and you get this much more fine
detailed looking like yeah they couldn't
have done that back in the day but like
the masks felt a little bit like a nod
and I also like that it's established
because the original Sylar is get
brought up and the doctor says a
different subspecies or different tribe
or like he acknowledges that they're not
exactly the same but they are sort of
generally speaking along the same lines
you know to cover for the fact that yeah
these ones look different which also is
in that far off because we've already
established multiple branches because
the sea Devils are related to the
Silurians that's more classic era see
Devils are another classic era I monster
who really should come back at some
point but anyways there are nitpicks
to be had with this
because the overall plot and concept and
the themes I would say are all solid the
the ideas being explored through the
Silurians the ideas of you know trying
to find a way to basically share the
planet with two rival sides you know
people on either side getting overly
emotional in a way that damages the
possibility for peace and you know
things like that
it's it's good ideas and a lot of those
core ideas are approached pretty well
but there's a lot of oddities and things
that don't quite work in the fine
details
I mentioned Nazarene and said that she's
a really good part of the reason I
mentioned her is because the rest of the
supporting cast is okay there's a couple
of things working against them the first
is the fact that there is there's too
much time spent with them and wait who
are you this is impossible mode because
in my mind unless you're truly gonna
make that part of the story like say for
instance midnight did then you kind of
need to have your supporting cast get
over the surprise and shock of the
doctor in the situation kind of quickly
because you know you can make an
argument all human beings wouldn't get
over quickly they get yeah that's fine
but like for the sake of the story you
need to have them get over it quickly so
that we can move forward because we as
the audience already know who the
doctors that are accepting the situation
and having characters standing around
going no this is impossible for more
than like 10 seconds like didn't starts
to drag the thing downs and that goes on
for just a little bit too long and it
feels like it feels like a stalling
tactic it feels like a padding tactic
just to have them take longer to accept
what's going on there's also some very
odd little moments that serve the plot
but I'm like wait what like when the
gonna start giving you the more plot
specifics which just like the more
spoilery if you haven't watched it
lately go do that it's still solid it's
pretty good it's not terrible but I am
you know it might complaints which I do
I am gonna complain a little bit more so
when the kid you know they're fortifying
this church and the kid says I need to
get my headphones and leaves now okay I
can grant that there's some truth that
kids of that age can kind of get tunnel
vision or can think oh I have the time
to do this one really they don't like I
can accept oh okay but I'm sorry whether
I can say that I could believe it might
happen or not it still makes that kid
look incredibly stupid and the context
of this show
he leaves the fortified building in
order to go get headphones really yeah
and then there's weird little things
like the doctors you know he notices oh
they're coming up from underground he
rigs up this thing and he's like ooh
heat signatures but then a little bit
later he goes out in the woods and he
can't see them with with like infrared
or like thermal or something because
they're cold blooded well if they're
cold blooded what the heck were the heat
signatures I feel like this needed a
pass from an ender just just to catch
some of this stuff and also like
seriously why in the hell is part to
open with this narration from the like
the leader of the Silurians why like it
it tells us absolutely nothing that the
episode just shows us like there's no
new information and it's weird and
jarring because it wasn't in part one it
doesn't set anything up it doesn't
better explain it anything and then when
it shows up again mid episode like over
the over the negotiations between the
Silurians and humans it's like whoa why
it's no it's it's a whole it's a whole
big old thing
no totally unnecessary I also take some
issue with the depiction of I'm just
gonna call her the general of the ardent
wrestling wrestling I can't remember the
character's name but the the one who's
leading the military forces of the
Silurians who's really pushing for
things to to escalate to war I I'm gonna
have to explain this because it's funny
I actually feel about this similar to
how I've mentioned in the past I feel
often about the depiction of religious
characters in some of the fiction that
I'd like to take in and I I find I take
issue with depiction of military
characters for a similar reason which is
that military leaders being shown as so
gung-ho for war that they'll basically
just start it themselves
and there's a couple of things I take
issue with that I mean I I'll be
completely honest I haven't known a ton
of people who've done military service
and nobody had you know at a commander
officer level I'll cop to that but the
people who I've known who have had any
kind of military service they don't want
to fight they don't want they want there
to be peace they take up the service
because they believe it's necessary to
take arms in order to help ensure it but
they don't want war and I feel like
depictions and stories like this so
often show military people is actively
wanting a war now granted to a certain
extent you can chalk this up to a need
for vengeance because her sister does
get killed but even before that she is
so gung-ho and then they push her to the
point why couldn't let me back up let me
say that like to some degree I
understand the logic behind depicting
characters like this because there is
some validity I think to the idea of
somebody with the military mindset is
going to see any situation the militant
option first because that's just how
they have been trained and have been
living and that's how they think you
know it's it's the principle of when you
have a hammer everything looks like a
nail
so you know diplomats always push for
diplomatic the military not necessarily
push for the military option but that's
the way they think so that's the first
thing they're gonna bring up there's
some validity to that and I get that but
when you push it to the level that
episodes like this take it to and I've
seen done lots of other places where she
actually murders a member of her own
species in order to ensure that she can
instigate a war I'm like and again much
like with what I've talked about with
the depiction of religiously minded
people in in sci-fi and fantasy fiction
as being idiots like and lacking even
the most basic common sense simply
because they have faith that similar to
that part of what annoys me about this
thing with military characters being
this war hungry is that I see it so much
and I guess I'd like to think at least
it wouldn't bother me so much if I
didn't feel like it was maybe not quite
ubiquitous but the majority of times I
see an antagonistic military character
they they literally are craving war and
I I see it so often that it just know
like I've started to develop a real
strong distaste for it and it feels like
lazy cop-out writing that also feels
unfair to be completely honest because I
think you still could have made this
work without pushing her to that level
without having her kill a member of her
own species you could have it driven
more by her emotions as she acts rashly
you know because her sister is dead
because he can't really argue that
that's the case yes she gets emotional
but then she goes about doing stuff that
it really seemed like she already wanted
to do and do
a fairly calculated way so this doesn't
come across as rash or emotional
decisions this comes across as the those
military people right and I don't like
that yeah not that and that annoys me as
well let's circle back to something
pretty decent with Amy and Rory karen
gillan really sells the pain of Rory's
death and of trying to hold on to him
and then Matt Smith really sells the
melancholy when he realizes that she has
in fact forgotten him and everybody does
does really good work with that and I
actually like some of the lines in terms
of sort of explaining some of the tiny
whine meanness because you know Amy
brings up is is this what happens in the
future and the doctor says look some
things are fixed and must always play
out a certain way this is not one of
those times this is an opportunity it
was nice to see that happened this way
because I feel like most of the times
that fix points in time get brought up
it's because we are in one so we can't
change the nose I know this totally
isn't we could rewrite history and it
will be awesome if we could if we can
pull this off I liked that and relatedly
they did a very good job with the whole
thing of you know the Amy and Rory
waving at each other and then at the end
it's only Amy and she doesn't realize
that somebody's missing yet somewhere
inside she realizes something's off so
and and even though like I'm I suppose
this is one of the better uses of the
the Krakken time on an actual narrative
that it takes place in as opposed to
just kind of being there but you know
it's I still don't love the storyline
but for how it's used here and its
impact on the characters its impact on
Amy especially it's pretty dang well
done so this two-parter overall is a
mixed bag it's a solid reintroduction of
the Silurians keeping true to the themes
of the sorts of stories that were always
old with acai lorian's and the way they
were depicted in the way they would be
they would have things resolved for them
sticks really well to that Matt Smith is
doing great he has some excellent lime
readings a very important Breaking and
Entering sonicing and entering
completely different and Rory is great
and Amy is great in the character of
Nasreen is great but there's maybe not
an equal number but a pretty decent
number of things that aren't quite there
you know with the the supporting cast
that isn't Nazarene is just fine there
are ok they're not great the the
depiction of the military character I
have my issues with the kid acts like
such an idiot
in that moment little hiccups like the
oh it's a he signature oh wait they're
cold-blooded yeah yeah so it is a mixed
bag it's still pretty solid though I I
would put I wouldn't break rate it as
decent rated I don't rate what are we
doing I need to go to bed is what I need
to do so when was the last time you
rewatched this two-parter if you have
thoughts on it whatever they are whether
you re wash it recently or not drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it
bunch of stuff to do down there as well
you can support me on patreon it helps
grow the channel and helps me cover my
bills
there's additionally the good old
fashioned like and the SUBSCRIBE both of
which help and are greatly appreciated
plus other links down there besides
links to my social xand the book that I
wrote my peel box address is down there
if you want to send anything to that
address all sorts of stuff click on
links or don't you don't have to folks
at the end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meanings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]